a thousand miles west here spread over
40,000 square miles of our Great Plains
is probably the most spectacular the most
sudden incredible erosion this country ever
had millions of tons of topsoil blown
away 300 million tons in a single storm
farm after farm blown into the sky and
more funds more hundreds of thousands of
tons washed into our great rivers washed
in here into the 1500 mile long Arkansas
this river 70 years ago you can
almost walk across the flower
at the most sinister erosion
because it cannot be seen by
grain of many paths all are cultivated plants
the river nowhere in the world
has a demo of soil destruction
in place so swiftly and on so great a thing
we came to a town that copper farmers founded not
so many years ago go forth they call
him go forth it died with the saw
it died of the starter farming that
killed at the edge of the town we
came upon a scene that is part and parcel
of a roaded land migrant landless people
once the soil begins to go is as high to stop
in 300 years we counted a compliment and
became the richest nation in the world
but we have wasted our soils squandered it
at such a rate that in less than a century
more if we go on as we have in the past a
days of this mission strength living memory
if my land cry out against me or that the
furrows thereof likewise constrained let
thistles grow instead of wheat and conquer dead
of Barney jobs have been more than 2,000 years ago